I want to invite you to add something
powerful to your Sadaqah Jariyah list.
We're on a mission to teach tens of
thousands of people around the world how
to pray salah properly. Just imagine
this. You help someone learn wudu, how
to pray, how to recite Surah Al-Fatiha,
every Fajr, Dhuhr, Asr, Maghrib, Isha,
Tahajjud, Tarawih, every prayer for the
rest of their lives, you share in the
reward. When they teach [music] their
children, and their children's children,
the reward continues for you. For just
£100, you can help teach 20 to 60 people
like you learn salah. Donate today and
earn rewards that never stop. Okay, can
we go ahead with this, guys? We've done
our due diligence. We checked on who
we're actually, you know, USING AS A
SUPPLIER.
WHAT UP, BRO?
>> [laughter]
>> BRO, IS THAT CORRECT? BRO, 10K. 10,000.
YEAH, WALLAH. 10,000. YEAH, WALLAH. 10K.
10,000? WHAT? YEAH, WALLAH. YEAH,
WALLAH, BRO.
Say wallah. Say wallah, bro. 10K, bro.
10K.
>> Yeah, wallah. SAY WALLAH. IS THAT 10K?
YEAH, WALLAH. WHAT? 10,000. YEAH,
WALLAH.
BRO.
BRO, wallah I OFFER SEEN STUFF.
BRO, WALLAH I OFFER SEEN STUFF. NO.
BRO. WHAT?
10K.
BRO, SOMEONE just stole me THE 10K.
WHAT? 10K. YOU CAN'T. SOMEONE GET THE
10K, BRO. 10K.
BRO, get it.
Bro.
BRO.
BRO, [laughter] 10K.
>> [screaming]
>> 10,000. WALLAH.
10,000.
BRO. BRO.
BRO, SAY WALLAH YOU TOOK IT, BRO.
BRO, IF YOU SAY wallah someone slapped
me, please. Come on. Come on. SAY SAY
WALLAH SOMEONE SLAPPED
BRO, BRO.
We are teaching people how to pray. And
every time they pray, you get to share
in that reward. And when they teach
their children, and their children's
children,
the reward continues. Every Fajr, Dhuhr,
Asr, Maghrib, Isha, Tarawih, Tahajjud,
every recitation, you share in the
[music] reward. For just £100, you can
help teach 20 to 60 people like me learn
how to pray salah. Donate today. Donate
today. Donate today.